I got a nice video to kick fun kid off
today yeah it's not really nice don't
tell them
it's not really nice yeah hold on a real
live chin realize hey Brian good to see
you
hey buddy its [ __ ] rock Tuesday sorry
about Monday I was acting doing some
acting as you know but you held it down
with Andrew Schultz
and you brought the fire yeah what's
going on bro I mean what were you uh I
feel like I feel like you got a little
something for me what's going on why are
you looking at me like that why so now I
got a video I don't know why I'm excited
you're me like what the [ __ ] somebody
sent me this video and I don't know why
and I came home like yo we out show
Brian this okay and this well it's not
funny someone's life get taken this guy
didn't want to pay this one I this what
the comments are saying this guide
didn't it's a life sucked up man this
guy do you laugh a tragedy it's out
really so ridiculous and you know I
don't like this stuff yeah but this guy
didn't want to pay the tuition again to
zoo so here's you know what I'm not
paying I don't like these lines let me
jump on over this fence you can't do
that well you can we can't catch an
zebras exhibit you gotta check you got a
check hold there's water probably polar
bear polar bear I'm not going there
yeah couldn't your walrus could be a
seal but all right I don't wanna risk it
don't want to risk it now if you see
dirts like all right might be the
elefante still a little dicey a little
dicey with the alchemy the giraffe
African alchemy the giraffe E's giraffes
seem to be okay but they might hit there
my head but you but I feel that one guy
like my chance I'm still gonna pass I
like my gets an antelope
yeah boring animal ya know there's a
bird as a flight yeah sure now if I see
tall grass if I see gtalk grass well we
know what lives in the tall guys we got
Tigers in the tall grass Indian you know
I'm a tiger in tall grass
you're touching people that like if
friend people betray my friends I'm
always a tiger in the talk rest of those
people right we're a couple to El Tigre
El Tigre is right here homeboy
danger memo all right you know what I'm
gonna save my eight bucks that it costs
to get into this you gotta get money you
gotta borrow the money go into debt
going to debt you don't you know what it
is though it's a bit of sometimes you go
I'm just gonna do it maybe he's trying
to press a girl it's like lauda it's
like this poor young kid probably 15 16
he's got girls there he goes I'll swim
across we're in Queensland or wherever
where there giant saltwater crocodiles a
lot of signs I'm gonna swim and come
back I'm gonna touch the thing to come
back to show you how brave I am and then
they have a family you ain't coming back
they're from dureena a saliva that's a
young boy that's a young boy trying to
do it for a girl this is a grown man
who's probably trying to save some
pennies went you know what [ __ ] this I'm
gonna get in there I'll meet you guys at
the snow cones or the funnel cake yeah
see in there losers so crime doesn't pay
sometimes jumps man jumps see you in
there losers jumps chin hit it let me
expand this a little bit so you could
see clear that's not one Tiger though
it's a squad squad up ready Tigers go
out on an old video so there he is on
the ground there he's right here
they're like are let's save them the
guy's a girl thank God Jesus Christ all
right I'll pay I'll pay and the other
girls you know what I'm not scared those
musket guns Oh Oh No
you've had enough oh he got him by the
neck but at least this they can't hit
him oh they're shooting so I shot the
guy there yeah why I want to kick off
the episode like that but how about
here's my finger are those musket guns I
was gonna say no they are they might be
salt guns or something that they're
shooting
sort of in the directionality and I'll
not kill the animals here's the thing
though they someone would just stop see
there's bad aim
someone hit the guy it looks like that
yeah can I which which couldn't have to
be more but let me watch it again
because I want to see cuz it looks like
you got him yeah take it in he does get
hit see my thing is he's like I I'm
getting it right and no one shot him in
the leg I think this isn't just another
thing we don't know what do you think
it's Chinese I think it's Chinese too
and I and it looks like we are they
Bengal or Siberian type now Siberian
these are bangle 700-pound that's why I
think they're bangalter it might be
bangle - yeah cuz they're not q don't
get in its territory though have those
turn the back some big boys aren't
they're big boys Oh
LT great they're big yeah a bit the one
that dips out look look he's like I'll
thank God all right I'll pay okay man
just be cool man he might have been
trying to commit suicide the whole
Haggar doesn't give a [ __ ] oh it's just
so instant yeah you're dead there you're
dead there he did look his neck now
right here what you'd rather break that
right there it shoots a Melissa no I
think he just died Wow it's a quick way
to go it still Tiger Tuesday it's it's
it's El Tigre Tuesday yeah well you
wonder if the guy was trying to commit
suicide fascinating right yeah yeah
apparently is with some friends
oh he was yeah fascinating because
Tigers grabbed the back ear in a key and
and here's the thing all those animals
dude though all right yeah I heard from
a tiger specialist that they have they
have I guess nerves in their canines
that can sense they can feel a pulse so
their their teeth are sensitive to feel
where your juggler is so they keep
adjusting your bite so I'll get you now
and now you can break it the average
man's neck without with something a
crack right you could you probably think
be tough I guess yeah but I mean you
could pull their head yeah
tiger I would imagine his jaws are a
little stronger than your arms I like to
thing yeah so I'm gonna say dr. ho book
thankfully went very quickly no he
didn't though cuz early on he like was I
yell thank God all right man I'm just
gonna get out of here well he got
probably was bit on the shoulder
something you've got to cover the top of
your neck huh
yeah cover up everything just came
around didn't give a [ __ ] about the guns
here this is how you know it's China
have you heard have you ever been a zoo
in America and seen more than one tiger
yeah never it's always one badass
yeah it's kind of the main attraction
it's hard to get one main event hard to
get in the case to a lot of times
impossible yeah because there's a moat
yep there's a moat but there's also I've
never seen there's like need [ __ ] 13
tigers strolling around yeah a lot of
tigers and you know tigers they say have
personalities some are fine others do
you not allowed to go anywhere that
thing just let him go what cuz the gun
poor man look at his head - his heads
like oh it's like I said though that's
why I also likes this video I can't tell
maybe just right here it's off like that
good god that thing is powerful
it's a giant cat it didn't give like a
musket guns either the way it's whoops
them right there - it's not shooting
Falco it may have hit him though they
may have they may have shot the tiger
and that's why you don't see any dust I
don't know it's too late though it's too
late I'll show jin-tae and shingles you
like these kind of videos like you know
I absolutely don't have to this one's
kind of grainy looks like you might
happen 1997 so I can watch it yeah it
goes like hi-def that's the other thing
I don't know if it's China because it's
China there unlike the iPhone 21 there
so here I'd f5k yeah this is super low
quality it's a very strange morbid
curiosity when we see an animal kill a
human that way you will you never see it
you never see it you know you know there
is there is one in India where the guy
is praying fell into the enclosure saw
that one and that thing grabbed him and
ran off with him yeah just ran off but
you don't see him kill him you see me
yeah yeah oh but my imagination I can
run there what happens nothing runs off
of them though a grown man I don't know
but they really don't let them get us
after scaling wall yeah boy your
interation fee this is the one we were
watching I don't know yeah that's a
different one guy what year was this
that's me [ __ ] man that poor [ __ ] know
what that is look if you look at the
mound
all right there see that yeah sister on
17 yeah China is not as advanced at
Korea's home here goes Tiger model death
at China Chinese Zoo is under
investigation by local authorities who
say
victim climbed offense and Tigers
enclosure yeah no [ __ ] the tight Curt
Saturday all right okay victim defense
surname is saying now
oh hey climbed a fence with a friend of
mine a ticketed wife and two children
statement said Zhang's wife and two
children as well as friend wife bought
tickets them to the zoo zaniel allegedly
passed through a wire netting eventually
climbed a wall and you know he was
probably trying to do anything that
money was friends honey nobody it gave
his kids about he's probably very poor
like it's in this family you bring
tonight no I'm gonna say give his family
the tickets and said I'll a again no I
can be with my family no way that's so
sad to me man
ah you know don't make it's a doubt that
story
if everyone had tickets he's like I'm
not on your team zoos are [ __ ] stupid
I'll see in there dummies and may not
have been I don't make you're a bastard
and you don't you're a bastard
mom poor guy poor guy I hope his family
and wife didn't see that I really do the
tiger can hope they didn't oh my gosh
how could they not we saw it that's all
the commotion that's going on at the zoo
suicide of 2017 yeah well that's this
report isn't 2017
why does I wonder that's how I wanted to
kick out you [ __ ] el tigre Tuesday
yeah yeah well I don't see I can't I
like if I watch like I remember when I
was in high school maybe when that one
like the Daniel Pearl one remember that
he'll be like never watch that was like
the first one that went mainstream yeah
I remember me and J working at all
seasons in the summer there's a guy who
worked there who was off you know just
he's off man I lost super yeah off dude
weird dude listen the [ __ ] real like
death metal and was always like where
dude like you'd be like oh he shot up
place but yeah no [ __ ] so he had it on
his laptop and I remember hearing like
oh no I can't I can't
and then I came back and I just saw like
just a little piece that's all you need
I couldn't I had trouble sleeping for
weeks and I close my eyes I see that
stuff some guy showed me without any
warning something like that that this
cartel did to a guy and I went I didn't
know what was going on at first I what
am I looking I went oh my god I
my buddy saw two and he called me up and
he goes
I'm still thinking about that I go you
should still be thinking about that
because they ruined my whole [ __ ]
week oh dude you know that because I
feel like I don't want to see that stuff
need add to another human being
man in a bum you know Wow humans can do
that's other human Roscher that's
[ __ ] - my mother used to always say
anything you can think of has been done
to another person because it's a human
look when people are you know people
have imagination for cruelty as theirs I
think with Jordan Peterson one time said
there are certain there are artists of
pain artists of pain and they come up
with ways innovative ways to tell me
have you seen dog [ __ ] with cats yet
sure have would you think well I are you
dealing with a true sociopath - sadist
who gets off on killing innocence Aston
a documentary yes fascinate
here's there's a new thing on Netflix
called I am a killer it's season - oh
yeah I mean it's I didn't see it I was
like out last night kinda seemed like at
the [ __ ] is it dude up - morning I love
love I don't know why I like to kill her
stuff first 48 detectives who is that
guy that's guys he's scary I think he
season one but that that lady's a
[ __ ] psycho oh she is listen to this
I feel like this might be it happen to
you one day you did a lot of killing no
well nope listen this so this lady was
like a like a big strong lady like I
don't probably did some martial arts
unless he being strong you know it's
like yeah so like like yeah sure sure
pooja - class that you see gym whatever
yeah so either way she fans herself was
tough lady but she was dating a guy
before she was dating this other guy she
was dating this guy don't show Brian
what happens don't spoil it she was
dating this guy who was abusive to her
and towards the end of a relationship
the guy actually went to jail for it he
made her look in the mirror and rear
naked choke her and said look in the
man's the last thing you see you're
gonna die
so he chokes are unconscious and then
she wakes up and he was God he got
arrested she called right he got
arrested but she had that like she hated
that about what that guy she had no
control so she starts you know kind of
drifting a little bit meets a guy kind
of smaller dude smaller dude and this
dude was a drifter and was using her cuz
she had a car was kind of they were like
they only knew each other for like
thirty days and he was trying to get to
Seattle
well they got romantically involved but
he's trying to get to Seattle because
the love of his life was in Seattle she
found out that he was trying to get to
Seattle because from other friends
they're like oh are you gonna see Kelly
and see Ali's like hopefully you know
hopefully we can make it work old
[ __ ] UFC gym three-class gets pissed
off cuz all really cool man
chokes um we're naked chokes and kills
them kills them we're naked choke them
and then in the in their way of dealing
with the humiliation of having it done
to herself or son didn't check this out
so but her story she goes well he was
super depressed and he asked me to do it
and so finally I told him I have a way I
could do it but he was a con see the
press asked me to do it
well they'll detect those yeah the hell
detectives give him all day but they
have all the footage of them you know
wait wait
she wasn't smarter than the detectives
yeah right in that great huh I mean the
mafia guys are spoiling the detectives
ya know but
so they've sitting down there you know
he's talking to her and she goes yeah
he's just so he's asked to do it and
he's like hmm so so let me get this
straight he asked you to kill him she
goes you know what's crazy is you know
when I was choking him and he went out
and this is the tech detective knows
this right it's something came to my co
she's definitely lying he was and you
know how they from jujitsu he does you
know she goes when I was choking them
you know and he was starting to gargle
and I was like no I can't do it he
grabbed my hand and put it back round
his neck legs like well that's not the
way the body works huh that's not the
way bar works and then he goes how long
you know each other 30 days 30 days 30
days and then way sitting down with her
they got you can you know how you know
they do it they get all cool with him he
goes so I mean what's going on here you
drunk and she goes yeah he goes you're
you can tell you said she goes you're
stronger let's see we can handle
yourself she goes goodbye and she goes
yeah yeah you bet you do like that he
goes yeah she goes yeah I always wanted
to feel what it's like to kill somebody
with my bare hands
and then here detect oh there you go
they come close they go she's now what
[ __ ] but he asked me to do it the tags
oh sure sure life in prison we have to
do some life life in prison yeah we
gotta do some life like well you're in
life when you go I've always wanted to
feel what see
can't have you guys talk with me if I
was a lawyer don't say to the detective
I've always wanted to see what it's like
to kill somebody with my bare hands
because what happens is the jury goes oh
we can't have you out there because you
might want to do it get down for life
I'll see you did it before gone for life
Wow she's got some I like I like her
shoulders she's got some arms on her
butts deceive ever seen here's the other
she deserves it
here's the other thing though so homeboy
who was murdered his family it's kind of
his stepdad who's insanely out of shape
his stepdad and then his mom who they
were they didn't talk to you for six
years they're this documentary [ __ ]
trying to get some clout and they're
like yeah that's terrible but we forgive
her and they're [ __ ] called her every
day she's singing them songs and [ __ ]
and then they go the homeboys family who
was murdered the rest of them the dad
the sisters the brothers of friends are
like they don't want any part of this
they don't believe this story they think
the pit is the step down the mom are
just doing it to get attention for they
have some weird cause that they're doing
it was real it was such a bummer man Wow
and she's single now
I mean she's looking for a pen pal
zombie somebody married [ __ ] Charles
Manson I'm just saying I mean some guys
like a strong strong aggressive woman
with the show is interesting she looks
like she's she looks like she's got a
good body she's a [ __ ] that's my
girlfriend she's your type it's just it
God knows some people are so female
sociopaths apparently are very rare as
nails yeah so says I think every year
yeah
the show starts off with like something
like every year eight thousand something
homicides happen and less than ten
percent are female yes so it's like
usually those women are doing it because
they've been abused they did they're
it's a reaction to something men don't
really need much Arenado my guys we
gotta wear knows that pull all dude that
poor guy why would a bad guy know well
it's alright it's tough man you make
your decision so it's episode to know
that you got broke many times but here's
thing use born his Monbiot wanna so he
bounced around to foster care foster
care
fine he gets no good family yeah until
he's about eight and then the family
goes hey homegirl got a job in England
and we can't bring you over there go
back to foster care sir so he's like oh
why must did something wrong right
so they send back Foskett did some dude
guide teacher drives a bus picks him up
he's like God first it's all good they
starts touching them starts molest him
then he gets two more kids starts much
so he's molesting all the kids
for all these years right but then the
grandma and grandpa lived next door or
last thing he raping them yeah so so
he's molest these kids for all these
years and these kids are terrified of
him but the guy the molesters
mom and dad lived next door which are
his grandma grandpa who he loves so he
never said anything so he's about 21 22
goes I I've had enough I'm gonna go tell
grandma grandpa what's going on he tells
him they blow up on him you're a piece
of [ __ ]
you're a liar so never do that so he
goes knife jakey's get fish just Koosh
Koosh Koosh Koosh a lot of stabbing hmm
more than you guys know that's what it
sounds like when you're stabbing I'm
nine nice I need first oh nine nine
somethings about 90 and then so he
changed up the knives yeah then you come
back in separate right hit but they in
even out he know he's in he's in for
life he did get the death point but they
went back and you know we got his case
on how much use molest and all that
funny camping
yeah they just gave him life you
watching [ __ ] tragic do you have kids
yeah how about you know when I have an
eight-year-old he's five walking out
like on his own just like ah [ __ ] dude
now that kills me is when you have
children that's what I see a guy got sad
my heart hurts right now oh when they
talk about lighting I think of Tigers
I'm like oh I saw my little like here I
go can you imagine those parents that
can you imagine leaving Tiger on his own
on the street at five no no it is
knowing you know that's there's so many
people who are in jail so many went
through the foster system if you really
want to make a difference you figure out
a way to get parents good parents
because I tried to work with this foster
thing and and the guy who had gone
through the system who was one of
one's amazing cuz he wasn't being a jerk
he goes well it's adorable that you want
to give money what we need is a parent
he's family we need family adopted kids
said yeah and I would like to I really
told my girl I adopt a little girl right
now I honestly would I honestly what I
want to and again you know what's [ __ ]
up about that it's impossible I have all
I have I'm so busy I have time for my
children and that I don't have enough
time for that you know it yes I don't
know man it makes me honestly I'm a
table like a 21 year old kid you have an
assistant he they sleeping it out I'd
like to I'd like I have a house and you
have 21
I now dude I'm working for all hey call
me daddy
yup food in a room though I miss daddy
call my dad that's your dad you're my
assistant
I'm assistant I'm assistant yeah you
watch that I'd like to have a house
where you you take in I don't know
[ __ ] six the boys who are five four
and take care of them the little girl
make sure that they're safe if it has
been needed yeah and have sin and have
two other people to help you and and and
give them a life Despicable Me yeah you
need minions to raise them I [ __ ]
feel I really should do feel like I'm
gonna do that eventually I swear to God
hey hey Bubba what you 60 50 G gray :
53 get going I think it might be my
life's calling if I make a lot of money
I swear to god I might do that I'm not
sure hey you make enough money right now
what you waiting for
cuz I got them busy yeah yeah there you
go I'm just trying to get real for you
yeah you gonna do it yeah well if I have
enough money well how much money I don't
swear you make you can do it you just
can't with your time it's like I don't
have the time I don't I know I remember
others may it kills me yeah for the next
hour we'll know tomorrow well just I
think about it all the time like you
know you and I have kids right so you're
right when yeah like that happened that
little boy and that's happening now and
there's not change it we can do or my
stepmom did the big sister thing she did
you know the big sister little sister
yeah I looked into that so they I had a
friend who did that - it's it's it's
tough because ya just
they set an example but I remember you
know this girl was not that cool and it
was weird cuz I said I want to spend
that much time with us like was this
mexican chick in our house I just found
this out my one of my one of my dear
friends in high school
he only had his mom and he always said
that my dad never knew my dad my dad
walked out of me and he was like [ __ ]
just the craziest athlete we'd ever seen
in that in high school and he was like
yeah my mom told me my dad was a
bodybuilder or whatever whatever but I
remember always feeling bad for my
friend because his dad had he'd never
knew his dad crazy mom was a nurse he
had no money all right so he he's 50 or
whatever he's through his whole life and
he does it 23andme because it was given
to him as a Christmas things like
whatever the [ __ ] guy finds out he's
got like three sisters two brothers and
his dad was always in the picture his
dad was a was a calculus teacher a high
school calculus teacher a great guy then
became a principal and never knew he had
a son because he's his mother um yes and
his mother just never told us the plot
Joe the man never [ __ ] knew he had a
son and so the his his brothers and
sisters looked him up and went hey and
now he's got this relationship and
they're like well you know it's all this
he's like I could have used the guy and
he died of a heart attack the year
before that's he was in his car he died
of a heart attack death but it was crazy
because he was like that was my man his
egos my our dad would have loved to have
had another son if he had known you such
an athlete and said anyway it's neither
dead I remember that I was like what
laughing bucket is a stirrer
that's crazy my hands if my hands seem
like they're you know I apologize oh
yeah you know my favorite part of that
video what my favorite trainer I know
Shirley Leonard yep my favorite tears
you go oh my god you're filming that
this is not I didn't know yeah I swear
to god oh my god no oh my god let's just
start filming no this
this is crazy sly said sly said so I
said the person over there he goes hey
get this on video you crazy get this on
video cuz he was ti I swear to God I had
no idea I swear to God I didn't know I
would tell you I didn't I didn't know
but this thing I got I got so much
longer we were doing this for [ __ ]
ten minutes how many people are like
dude and I got a dealio whoa I got I got
a thing where he's hitting me in the
ribs and pulling it back and that was
this thing it was for the Super Bowl
yeah and look at sly watching so I said
you made right there he starts hitting
so I said you made the right choice in
fact yeah sly looks good man looks
[ __ ] great
Sugar Ray looks better than all you guys
dude unbelievable yeah I told you I said
how do you say what's your CRT team
assemble now he goes I'm vain that's
what this I don't think he's doing
charity at all I think he's just
physically he doesn't care teams I love
you for that
that's why I love you you think he's
doing it everyone not householders so
for the chicks yeah I don't know and you
and me and me D'Elia I'm suspect on he's
getting up there day you walk did I go
oh hey bro there's not around you want
steroids he goes dude I just some tablet
I spend lifts Daniel yeah I get out
lifting works for tea you should put on
muscle like this he is right now dude I
just I never really left and I'm lifting
and and eating right up and then I get
it man he goes yeah I'm lifting huh I
know all that I hear you that's that's
great dude okay there's no around dude
yup steroids he goes God get out of here
what so I went yeah all right dude he's
definitely not Mary he's definitely not
Chris would never know well I mean you
know no I'm still afraid of Chris of
steroids oh okay that's good I mean I'll
help him I'll take what God yeah I don't
know
yeah I don't he doesn't look muscular
right he just looks good he just looks
like he's just yeah but do not crash
right
that's my favorite I had no good actor
senior good I swear to God I say can I
Instagram this who's the other black guy
ah let's race friend Jerry do you calm
ray-ray I did not lie wait
what's up ray-ray call him champ or a
comrade becoming away so blow ray little
racy ray-ray really yeah nope don't do
that don't know ray-ray
no calm right okay don't you call no
disrespect I get on call champ you calm
ray I come ray yeah Oh God I come I come
ray yeah you call Sylvester Stallone's
fly though even his kids call fly it's
great it's kids don't call dad they call
him sly it's hilarious sly what what
this kids calling fly everybody calls
him stuff wrong with that why why they
call him slack you tell you Brian or
bright huh you kids call your bride uh
my daughter does sometimes just to annoy
me it's so funny
he couldn't be closer to his good
daughter so it's [ __ ] hilarious
his daughters like this is why I never
leave like go back to that let me see
him in Rambo let me see him to Rambo oh
there you go when he's young his body
that's awesome
kids got a body bite it up body the [ __ ]
up do you like the game I did like the
game I liked it very much now I was
rooting because our boy tarkas even
works for the 49ers we have a couple
friends we know Jed York yeah but um
Kansas City I don't know anything about
football I sent you that video because
here's me here's me here's what I want
to do it like my uber drivers or
whatever start talk to me about football
asked me about Kansas City and stuff
like that and what I think know what you
think Kansas Citian I tell you my home
is the real deal he's the real deal
people are doing this thing believeth I
do this this is me I don't know but I
just start to parrot you and I go it's
it's way they're so rare to get a
quarterback like this because you know I
mean look what they did with Archie 3
they forced him in the pocket now he's
gonna be back for you babe the backfield
and those holes quick coke no it's
[ __ ] I'm not high
okay you got it the thing is if you run
they're gonna force you to pass if you
have passed they're gonna force you to
run
that's the nfm you say you some guys can
just have that they have that x-factor
we do instead slice else oh I'll do it
everybody cuz I'm I got yeah yeah drops
you understand yeah I parrot [ __ ] yeah
but I do think that might might my
assessment was Mahone and Andy Reid
moves
mahomes an enemy said let's just hurry
up offense they scored and that would
that just change the momentum that's
just [ __ ] changed everything and
they've come back from behind I think in
the past three times yeah
and that just that shadow shows his
greatness he's so good so good there you
know what again here's what I think I
don't think at the end of the day maybe
better team the better team one right or
no I don't know Sam Cisco is pretty stat
phenom the thing is as Kyle Shannon Kyle
Shanahan who I love would grow up the
same neighborhood
Kyle Shanahan you know when he was the
offensive coordinator for the Falcons
when they're up 21 points in the Super
Bowl years ago when they played the
Patriots and lost so he has like this
weird kind of it's almost like play
calling me not to lose when they get
ahead it's very strange without the NFL
you get up by that many points kind of
game over yeah kind of game oh yeah
unless you blame Tom Brady so what do
you mean playing not to loosen not know
he stops - I got him the head so they
start to turn away as nervous yeah
trying to yeah waste time run the ball
more being a little more cautious
instead of just playing what got your
head for the get-go and and as the head
coach are you the primary shot caller or
your option anis sometimes they're not
sometimes their offensive coordinator is
often sometimes the head coach is a
defense specialist it might have more
influence on the defense than offense or
sometimes the head coach he'll come up
with the game plan but there's offense
defense coordinator and hey coach
conscious waking game time here let's go
for on fourth down or let's run this
play or this but there's often Stevens
corner you're talking to your your
people the whole time but ultimately
it's like to be in the president it sure
comes down to your comes down you're
uncertain but Kyle Shahan runs though
he's one of the coaches who do run the
offense really like Sean McVeigh because
you intensive runs the office because he
was not offensive coach is that actually
they do all they do run and then when
the quarterback you see the quarterback
sitting down looking at you know the
tablet yeah what's he doing there - he's
looking at the defense line up to
certain formations what coverage there
and how they're hiding
you know blitzes and certain accounting
coverages just so we can recognize it as
the game yeah what they're doing in
certain packages is so fascinated with
the incredibly detailed
that's my patch from home so good he
recognized the off the defenses Mart
analyzes it it should be like a finite
and he didn't play great he'd have a
good game yeah he was off well he just
but but he like he's that poise under
pressure of just being able to do it and
just throw in those Boston well his
daddy was a professional baseball player
so he may he played baseball too or he
played some baseball and then his
uncle's a-rod he was a rod was his uncle
- say what yeah apply by blood I don't
think guys love but he writes his
Godfather
so a rod like put him in the position to
- but a rod put him in the position to
like you know just he he doesn't crumble
under pressure like the moment can't get
big enough for wow he's that guy that's
a huge part of it also a big sturdy kid
much bigger much taller than you would
think and just thick and strong and fast
goddamn he does everything well runs
throws everything and just a winner boys
about to get paid he is right about to
get paid stud what a stud Wow and he's
24 I think 24 25 is so crazy I know
right
[ __ ] he looks so yeah how are you the
biggest contract NFL history you think
so yep really let me think about it
NFL MVP well he's super aligned VP worth
its weight and yeah [ __ ] oh he's the
most famous again he doesn't laid right
it's not cute girl something was here
all right you know it's girls cool yeah
well now it's about school now let me
see his girl since high school or
they've been dating okay it's good
because you know girl crazy do you look
do you know who I think his name's Ken
Brown the country's yeah have we ever
seen them in the same room who they're
the same guy which gets to the country
singer and Patrick Mahoney oh the same
guy came looks like Pele
let me see okay we're talking about the
the the mix kid yeah
to me let's patch my homes that's okay
what about this Nazi yeah I know it's
like Patrick Holmes yeah you know that's
a black bag feels white bro no I mean I
can see cuz they're both male and
they're human you know I see what you're
saying cuz they both have eyes have eyes
they have eyes you actively if he grows
hair he looks like Petra Mahone and they
talked have you heard their voices
they're exactly descent funny they're
exactly the same it's funny he's country
he's country like it yeah well mixed oh
man not seen race no I'm he's an athlete
ooh look at this look at his just say he
looks at her plates that he said go down
go down there hey yeah how how races is
counting because he's black there's
nothing more right so in the old white
guy goes uh-huh I don't know anything
how he started but then to the cherry on
top goes he looks athletic well he's a
singer his muscles yeah he's a see white
melee looks like my home he looks like
he could play the thing is I just don't
um he's black I'd not met I've never met
a black hunter I've never seen a black
country singer he's a Blowfish bro huh
arias Rucker well they're more like you
know art became no no no no dis records
them he is yes record oh yes he's still
huge feud I mean he's won so many awards
for country music really yeah you left
your eyes oh he did huh Wow he's all
country now I like this music - yeah man
it's good yeah me too I like them too
country to country guys African American
well I always thought of country as
being something that African Americans
don't like because it reminds them of
racism that's very I don't mean I'm
sorry guys I'm not my name's Brent shop
I have nothing to do with this you're
the one who said you don't think African
Americans to be in country music
you said it with your eyes how about
when you saw me that black guys in
country like huh well he's mixed huh
he's mixed and then the next thing come
on your mouth go looks athletic you know
Steven - blah
fired bring up Stephen supplies working
for ESPN Stephen Chbosky grew up in he
grew up in Dallas boom
Stephen Tobolowsky who's that yo CEO
seemed he's a [ __ ] hilarious plays
the principal on my know he's the
principal on on Kohlberg's and on school
to me this guy yeah right here you
hilarious you know him no oh he's so
funny he's him he's in one day at a time
he never stops working it was such a
funny [ __ ] actor been working
non-stop
and older you know he's now he's
probably but he told me he was in sixth
grade in Dallas and he was one of three
Jewish families like in all of that area
he's a groundhog Dino day yes yes well
commercial yeah hilarious well that's
right using the commercial with Bill
Murray I don't know where's and he he
said he walked in he was like the only
like subdued there were no Jewish people
in the school he was that nobody knew
his family was Jewish
that was a pediatrician that's still
alive 97 don't worry about it he walks
in he walks in and goes um he walks in
and goes
sixth grade it's it's a birthday party
for his classmates you know and as they
walk in there's a bust of Hitler with
two German flags like too late and he's
just like oh and he's in sixth grade so
he doesn't really know what the [ __ ] is
going on
and that was like just there because
they I guess admired recent German
history hexxus a haunting Dallas
probably in 60s this is in the 60s or
early 60s maybe maybe late yeah yeah
that's was like and then I said what
happened to the guy he sounds like and
he goes oh he he went to geo then ended
up killing himself and I didn't forget
your comments about Kane Brown
hey come on man I take them back did I
say at one point on this podcast that if
you are a single mom or single parent
raising a kid it's child abuse
no no thanks somebody I mean you
probably didn't make Instagram me I was
like probably what did I say that the
[ __ ] you talking about you I said if you
leave your job yeah yeah yeah you said
it you're a piece of [ __ ]
yeah which is all good yeah that's how I
feel I got a few questions
BYU reading you Tom I don't know you
over there and I was like I got this
thing long prayers I got was bored
because I'm bored because I'm bored
between shots so I'll do anything read
Tom you got you go on your foot you know
I dunno I'm deleting [ __ ] I read ever it
is I can do yeah I don't read comments
but under my post I read lucky in my
requests you tiems yeah sometimes that
sometimes I'm just like what do we do so
what um well I don't know you didn't say
that you're saying if a dad leaves a kid
with the mom that's child abuse yeah
yeah it's not yeah
or you or whatever it is you [ __ ]
yeah I don't like that did um do we have
any fights coming up in the UFC Jon
Jones Saturday uh-huh oh I know you had
your boy on Dominick race where's all
your money yeah yeah I love Dom but come
on yeah Dom doesn't have as much
experience he's been funniest 13 fights
yeah and your girl um Valentina
Shevchenko she's fighting that girl that
you know Katy Chuckie Guillen oh yeah
yeah I love Katy GKN shift shank is the
biggest favorite in the code and the
code rightfully so yeah she beat the
[ __ ] out that girl she's just a beast
and good luck I missed you see how that
pay-per-use gonna do carne [ __ ] Oh cards
bad it is it's bad it's custom fighting
no get out it's a fair sir sorry please
just don't
no no but what is he fighting I thought
history there's no hey talk about black
guys yet oh hey no come on I'm just
asking to show Brown the card quad Adams
and Justin Tapia tava um dan egg and
your Derrick Lewis Latifi low to you on
the card enjoy that letit was first by
the man ain't car that's not low I'm in
such a good that's a good way to kick
off a mean of card Oh spicy and put that
surge
uh-huh it's just a [ __ ] card though
I just don't know anybody that's you
know well you know John you know of
course I'm not a chef shank oh yeah you
know Derrick Lewis you know of Latifi
yeah and really remember she had the
boyfriend with the Nazi tattoo your
buddy we had let's keep going can't just
you can't just skip over that man
I'm not saying yeah I got a Hitler bus
in my house but that doesn't mean it
Hitler buses just his face sculpted I
mean J Radames through the weekend we're
in Columbus why is it why is it that B&B
was like maybe you dude but it's all
over on History Channel Amy like why are
we obsessed with Nazis also we don't
know what [ __ ] Nazi what they do it's
terrible yeah why we so I think they
really not see I'm a impersonate on a
bashing
like they're just so blatantly racist
and they they also exterminated almost
his CEO succeed an exterminating entire
race and it was done very importantly by
a very civilized society that read
Goethe and had architecture and this
these were people who were were you know
educated here's what slightly edgy
because when you think about like what
goes in obviously our boys talk about
the hyena boys talked about how Hugo
Boss made their out their uniforms yeah
Porsche the the lead designer of Porsche
went to prison for war crimes because he
helped make the cars and the engines for
Nazis I thought it was Paul's wife
Porsche okay what he actually served
time in prison because of it yeah after
the war well it yeah and and remember
this was the argument against you know
just pure atheism and rationality they
looked at the Jews especially Hitler as
a quote unquote problem and so were that
and then they had this science this Nazi
science that started in the US it
started in the US eugenics the notion
that you know there was a way to make
better people through selective breeding
you could do it with animals why not
people and that
was taken by the German scientists who
looked at that quote-unquote research
from the 30s in the United States and
took it and their biology books and
stuff were all about sort of superior
races we did learn a lot from other
horrible experiences maybe I don't know
if they did or they say yeah I know we
also took all other doctors in the Oslo
desires doctors and scientists and
scientists went to NASA well a lot of
the scientists though a lot of these
scientists in Germany and Austria
remember like Albert Einstein emigrated
before the war because they were already
being assassinated and killed and
harassed so they they were already
emigrating to the United Kingdom and the
United States and though that brain
power is what we used to harness a lot
of the nuclear technology dude let me
say this now I don't know who needs to
hear this but Tom Cruise best movies
Valkyrie that's a good movie dude it's
on so much I want you to ever eat I'm
have a very good just true story - it is
oh yeah true story has a real head oh
yeah
you know there's over 300 assassination
attempts on Hitler yeah three hundo yeah
he was something about it has anyone on
Trump he was the only one crazy whenever
you read any history yo you'll read that
World War one was such a horrible war by
all accounts by all accounts it was so
horrific it was beyond imagination
because it was when technology like the
machine gun came along and people didn't
know what they were getting into right
so entire generations of men mowed down
it was a true slaughterhouse and Hitler
if you read his in a case Hitler seemed
to actually enjoy the war Hitler kind of
enjoyed World War one also vegan and and
late later on in his life he was a vegan
and you know also didn't want hurt
animals how not and like children and
animals hmm but um but also their own
shows sons tons of anti feta me like did
tons of tons of drugs he he he there was
a doctor who said when he then he had
been mustard gas so he was blind for a
while after the war and this this German
doctor said this man is unfit to command
people or to command anything he was
just he conceived listening to him talk
and he was so outraged that Germany had
rendered he was just considered at the
great betrayal he was such a [ __ ] he
was the ultimate sociopath and
incredibly the astronaut career was
matter yeah any actor you know I mean
he's just the way he would speak about
die son
have you ever seen his speeches men
they're so intense there's so intense
there so dramatic so soft up on whatever
[ __ ] drug dealer back then on his own
ideology is really what it was celibate
that maybe was never [ __ ]
apparently died a virgin know what's
believe in that that's not real that's
what a lot of a lot of historians would
would disagree with that they they they
he was that was some type that in chin
he was celibate ever had sexy hose no
never had sex with Ava Braun so there's
a lot of new by various Hitler separates
the man from the myth you know who knows
what was going on with him small tiny
dick no deco no shoes that many
historians think Hitler was a virgin
this is New York Times never no no
Hitler had an intent some say perverted
relationship with his female cousin who
eventually commits suicide that's what I
knew he's [ __ ] up with his cousin Wow
I believe anything about it I believe
anything I don't I think he was a virgin
that's just not who knows you know
you're not that Pat you don't wanna be
that powerful not [ __ ] all the German
women I don't know they said he thought
it had a very platonic relationship he
was I&I and she took cyanide they killed
each other and he expected he was that
they killed that they took cyanide I do
and they never found the body
well they burned the body the bodies
were burned yeah but the skeleton stuff
they never and you know the body that
the the skeleton they have and you know
I'm a conspiracy guy but to that point
where they say oh he was Bert they you
know they shy each other than the Nazis
burn the body because they don't want
the you know us to get a hold of it and
the brains to get a hold of it so then
they had this this skeleton in Germany
right you had that then they into on
whatever 14 they're like let's run a DNA
test on it that's a female
it was so burned though apparently
beyond recognition the British I think
found and the Russians found his his
ashes yes here's the thing I think his
there no proof my guess is he was so
recognizable though that for him to hide
or be away would be an Argentine
possible yeah point Tim Kennedy beg to
differ
yes somebody Nazis went to yeah it makes
for funds into your ship but I think he
was the kind of guy who would have
killed himself I I don't know but that's
the things only no no I nobody know but
also thing is we have no evidence of his
body that's what's kind of well but he I
guess it was burned I whether the
Russians burn it or or his subordinates
no that was the plan he expected Germany
to self emulate he was that colossal II
that colossal a self-centered he but
expected that all of Germany would burn
themselves up with him because when you
look into it it's just like we have no
DNA nothing yeah we have nothing one of
the most fascinating characters and I
mean he changed for he changed Europe he
was the destruction of Old Europe and
the birth of the new Europe he had his
German Shepherd there it's crazy she was
kind of a brilliant yeah she actually
has a nice body
even back then yeah yeah wow what a true
sociopath anything I'll tell you who
else who wasn't far behind her might
have been just as all matter so we're
gonna kill her Joe steel yeah Stalin was
the worst boy Putin ain't too far behind
either now and that the same Putin's a
strong man these guys were well who's
the leader of the chechen in guy well
he's there he's a he's a putin puppet
but he's not a good guy
do you see what happened recently no
this blogger came out against him she
was having the blogger in france no in
france
mmm-hmm caught up with him in a hotel
room yeah killed him beat him with a
club I think he's dead yes I believe it
crazy you guys a bad guy that guy in
Chechnya bad guy is the MMA league
what's that he has an MMA league yeah of
course if you're in MMA look at it you
see the guys he his father was
assassinated
yeah Ramazan cut cut dear off Ramzan
Kadyrov trains himself but look we go to
news it's in the bad guy real a real
real bad guy I mean I mean he's a huge
khabib in yeah he's only 43 the guy who
died ya know the leader power at 40 35
kuduro his father was his father was a
leader and was killed by I think Pro by
by Chechnya independence fighters he was
blown up and he was a young man and you
know obviously he came to power and that
was that I am says he was murdered
especially cruel I'm sure I'm sure isn't
it where do you want the facts the
detail I know I mean Jesus so terrible
well you know the strength of country if
you want innovation you know nice things
like iPhones and fashion and all the
things we love in our culture you better
protect your dissidents your eccentrics
people that don't agree with the power
structure they should be allowed to
express themselves any way they want the
individual has to be protected and those
countries don't allow that if you don't
have fidelity to the leader and the
state you get killed which is why I'm
wondering if anybody could tell me what
what is there anything you could buy
from the Chechnya is there any any
innovation that comes out of there any
artistic innovation and technological
I'll wait I'll wait no the answer is no
because they're not creative because you
better have fidelity because there's one
man talk down command and it makes your
country weak not strong so whenever you
whenever you kill gay people like he
does where you criminalize them and
torture them and round them up and then
say that we don't have gay people in
Chechnya well that's what you get you
get a piece of [ __ ] like that with a
country who are all your creatives
either leave or keep themselves quiet
got it terrified so [ __ ] that guy says
people like him before leaves murder he
had received information that a hitman
from Chechnya had been dispatched to
Western Europe where this guy was
staying course ensured the details of
the man's itinerary with German police
say initially believed that the hit man
was targeting him he declined to reveal
the source of the information bad guy
but those guys have always been around
and they'll always be around if you have
a system of government that rewards that
kind of behavior yep yeah he's got he's
got I think MST International had him up
on a bunch of charges of being a really
bad guy now if you're a fighter if you
went there you're a fighter they love
you you'd be treated like a king in
Chechnya not doing no but that that's a
strong case that yeah that's a yellow
sugar my tank but that's a guy who
believes in strength that's there's only
one kind of strength and that's the one
with the guy with the biggest club if
you can if you can impose your will on
other people that's the only strength
that matters everything else is [ __ ]
that's how he thinks cuz it's not smart
he's just not educated he's just not
been exposed to other ideas some dark
[ __ ] we're lucky we're so lucky we live
in a country like this we can never have
a [ __ ] podcast like this in that
country and criticize that guy or
anything else that he didn't like would
mean it would be killed or tortured and
then you'd have to beat him up take over
Harry dude they're hairy people did you
ever you buy wrestled around with a lot
of those daghestani chess game guys
right no never never never trained with
those wrestlers you train with Rus
Russians some Russians yeah never
daghestani or the [ __ ] it is yeah yeah
yeah ever yerim mix it up with any
really good Russian Greco guys and get
tossed around I'm sure there's a few and
I remember them nothing like nobody who
was like whoa no Russians are gonna rush
in you know who are they who are the
best wrestlers you ever [ __ ] with look
at the Dagestani guys are Degas that's
good
right the whole wife that'd be a tough
guy to tangle up with they do in Jesus
Christ enjoy that it's got a curve that
I almost stare at [ __ ] wrestlers all
night that's a jack dude this guy looks
crazy to Christ type any country and get
some pretty cool wrestling bodies Jenny
there's a steroids you know you gotta
have good quality socks you want
performance socks you want socks
designed for running hiking cycling cut
out there going foo
you know getting down getting down I
need a performance sock B dude if you're
into sports or planning on getting into
sports about hiking and cycling cuz
everyone's own people bond boss
lightweight poly-cotton blend hot no
matter how hard you're working your feet
stay cool dry comfort do you talk about
performance socks for basketball tennis
running golf hiking yes doc said no your
foot I'm talking about bomba socks all
right it's like a hat for your foot it's
like a glove for your foot but it's a
sock they are the number one most
requested item and homeless shelters by
the way so momma songs created change
they're gonna do this for every pair you
buy bombas socks donates a pair to
someone in need that's pretty cool bo
m.b.a s.com slash fighter today bo m ba
s.com get 20% off your first purchase
so bombas dot-com slash fighter for 20%
off bombas dot-com slash fighter look if
you want hair if you want your piece to
stay hard
sometimes you'll lose your hair a lot of
guys at the 40% or 66% of men start to
lose their hair by 35 years old dude 40%
of men suffer erectile disfunction dude
the best way to prevent hair loss you
got to do something while you still have
it dude think what you could have done
yeah when you're in your 30s you're like
I gotta get on well that's why I do it
now it's why I'm mmm that's great I am a
- lover of hymns I'm a customer of hymns
I get my dude sermons from so much I'm
trying to make sure this stays thick
like this dude
a one-stop shop for hair loss skin care
sexual one is for men it's time to write
a new chapter one in which you have dope
hair no more awkward in-person doctor
visits or long pharmacy lines for hams
connect you to real doctors online we
could save you a corpse yes it's
confidential discreet nobody wants girls
doctors have my piece doesn't work all
the time so you can do it online answer
a few quick questions and dr. motor
review and they determine if it's right
for you dude well this let it grow let
it grow let it grow with him do dive
into 20/20 here first talent yeah your
first keep your piece hard 66% of men
before the age of 35 started losing
their 40 percent under 40 your erectile
disfunction yeah say goodbye to that you
got sciencebase you Lucian Longhorns
calm long hair stiff dick don't care
that four hands calm /f ATK hit him with
the disclaimer Brian here's the display
of a prescription regarding the online
consultation with a physician who will
determine if a prescription is
appropriate I've done it it was very
easy it was very fast offer valid only a
prescribed three month minimum
subscription additional restrictions
apply see website for full details
important safety information keep your
hair keep your piece stiff and ready I
am a customer for hands DJ longest read
ever okay no have you guys seen Joaquin
Phoenix's speech that's been going
around yeah so he was accepting his
award at the BAFTAs and he basically
asked us it didn't it's an acting award
show it's another one of those he
basically got on stage and he very
awkwardly talked about how he's a part
of the problem in Hollywood because he
is a white actor who has been supported
by Hollywood but Hollywood hasn't done
the same for people of color I mean I
disagree with that
just take your hair can award Joker
to be here tonight Baptists have always
been very supportive of my career and
I'm deeply appreciative but I have to
say that I also feel conflicted because
so many of my fellow actors that are
deserving don't have that same privilege
I think that we send a very clear
message to people of color that you're
not welcome here I think that's the
message that we're sending to people
that have contributed so much to our
media vancouver's in our industry and in
ways that we benefit from I don't think
anybody wants a handout or preferential
treatment although that's what we give
ourselves every year I think that people
just want to be acknowledged and
appreciated and respected for for their
work this is not a self righteous
condemnation who is Greta
because I'm ashamed to say that I'm part
of the problem I have not done
everything in my power to ensure that
the sets I work on are inclusive but I
think that it's more than just having
sets that are multicultural I think that
we have to really do the hard work to
truly understand systemic racism I I
think that it is the obligation of the
people that have created and perpetuate
and benefit from a system of oppression
to be the ones that dismantle it so
that's on us
[Applause]
okay all right
I think that's happening in a lot of
ways I mean I mean know what I mean I
don't think I'm Caesar or Hollywood
I think Hollywood is in comparison to a
lot of other places and parts the world
Hollywood's pretty good agree I mean
IIIi I'm not sure what else you want
Hollywood Hollywood started as a white
male dominated you know I mean if you
really wanted to get into it I suppose
Hollywood started as hot white male and
Jewish okay
because there was a tradition in that
culture of artistic individuality and
expression and so that's what happened
that's who built Hollywood and Hollywood
is now exporting product to people all
over the world and it makes economic
sense to diversify story and the people
that tell those stories you have Asian
you have black but I think that
hollywood's doing a pretty good job I
would suggest do what the marketplace
wants there are plenty of people of
quote unquote color looks it annoys me
that that's a who are looking for
stories that reflect their own
experience okay let's all let's see what
the best stories are let them rise to
the top I think a lot of times we get so
worried about this that a lot of movies
that aren't so good get an award because
you know like moonlight and stuff like
that I don't know I mean was it the best
movie I don't know but what happens is
that's that's even a bigger problem if
you're gonna start like Shh shoehorning
in diversity mm-hmm let it happen
organically and I don't know that
anybody that most people in Hollywood
that I've been around I've been here
I've only been here 27 years so I don't
know much but I've I've always noticed
how inclusive it is I think with Joaquin
Phoenix's do some dude did you do
nothing this is just again this is just
virtual signaling like you're not doing
things next time maybe it's a speech and
it's just you
you headlines and then okay next time
they give you a role like I know give to
that bad guy yeah you know and that's
nothing to share that movie was a bunch
of mental illness and and an isolated
young men so that's an important movie
and and those people his girlfriend
those people aren't thinking about white
and privilege there's a lot in the movie
though yeah correct
so okay you know I don't know man that
movie was saying something but I don't
think I think and I liked it I think
you're gonna do [ __ ] I need to [ __ ] yeah
any do anything well bottom lies you
can't drink in a war next year if you do
the same movie geez I can do anything
it's also like I'm gonna talk about open
up [ __ ] you know these these homes for
kids yeah you guys gonna do [ __ ] yeah
you want to I want to get another agenda
Hollywood is always Hollywood was all
about transgender stuff than they were
all about global warming and they they
they they tend to you know pay and you
know actors want to be liked and so you
know the country knows this the whole
country anytime you have an actor get
behind you it you know when when Taylor
Swift who I saw a documentary on ER
which I kind of enjoyed you watch the
documentary a little bit just to see
what she liked you said like that dance
I wasn't too okay yeah but she got
behind that this this Martha Blackburn
or her [ __ ] her name is a Tennessee I'm
in a hardcore conservative really
against gay marriage and all that stuff
tell us what said you know why would you
vote why would Tennessee does she
tweeted don't vote for a homophobic
racist you know or something like that
in office and like a bunch of her
followers came out and [ __ ] you know
voted but Marsha Blackburn still 162
percent to 32 percent or whatever it was
so it it's sometimes if you're a
political candidate having someone like
Sean Penn or whoever it might be in your
corner is a bad idea the country's very
suspicious of actors and should be not
cuz actors are bad people with a lot for
their emotional element fake their
emotionally
they're important not real people to us
like they're playing like why can't see
listen man I like walking Fink's he's
crazy let's let's get this he's crazy
yeah legit crazy so it's like all right
here's anxiety you don't like to talk
take him with someone Genda yeah you
know yeah you know I probably with a guy
like him he's like I have this
opportunity let me try to say something
and make the world a better place
I don't want to just be an actor and
winning this award and the mistake is be
a great actor which is what you are and
and say speak through your work do it's
do a movie about that maybe you know
that's where you'd get the most impact I
don't know about making a speech but put
it in your work we finance a movie
that's that that tells a great story
about that and changes hearts and minds
when Harriet Beecher Stowe wrote Uncle
Tom's Cabin there is the the rumor
whether it's true or not historically
that that Abraham Lincoln said yura the
little woman who wrote this book that
caused this great war when you read
Uncle Tom's Cabin and you were and I
read it it is so powerfully it is such a
powerful story against slavery and in
people in the North read and they go
this is the most horrific thing they're
selling children from under their
parents but no and it's in it galvanized
the war effort in the north it was it
was a book and it had a lot to do with
why the north
stay historians would argue we're able
to sort of get behind this war effort so
criticized by creating my favorite
quotes but also Joaquin Phoenix he's
done all these awards he's touched on
climate change she's touched on he has
said you terian
so it's like yeah he has hasn't he
literally everyone's a different agenda
well that's a little bit of a Messiah
Complex listen I'm not following that
guy anywhere no I don't make Joker -
hola Chico C is moving you'll make joke
- I'm in I'll go see his movies but I'm
not like that I'm out dude
and I don't I don't think that's lost on
most people I think most people go hmm
first of all you're calling all of his
racists are a part of the problem uh-huh
I don't feel that way I'm not that I'm
not a racist I'm not even a little bit
racist
and I try to do the best I can with what
I have and that means that's why I'm
opening a number of orphans and then his
uh during the globe speech he got tweet
got blurred most of it you didn't see at
home because he yelled out there's no
[ __ ] best actor well just take the
award dude the other is theirs though
yeah there is and you were it you were
great
just take it man I mean I take it easy
can't take the love you know here's so I
mean yeah he's gotta be his therapist
probably God Jesus yeah there's a I
think you're right about that
he's a very dispersed his therapist just
like yeah i from what i understand hi
what do you got man he said you want all
these awards yes still not happy yep yep
I told you all right let's unravel this
he's a very very sensitive mind Stan and
delicate fella
his social anxiety don't like to give
talked so he had to come up with some
sort of spiel though he looks like he's
holding his breath the whole time you
know yeah and mmm-hmm phenomenal actor
though he's phenomenal phenomenal you
won you did best best boy he looks he
looks so much healthier in that movie he
just looked skinny unhappy rolled though
man
he's eaten again yeah what else we get
great hey Crazy's gonna crazy right it's
crazy it's gonna crazy it's gonna crazy
Tigers gonna [ __ ] bite and touch
please get it crazy I gonna bite crazy
gonna crazy
I mean he's also I playing the game
right when I when I saw this it reminded
me of just playing the Hollywood game
this is what you do to get more you know
roll yeah beep liked by people yeah I
just I see I see that like transparent
think everyone does yeah but us when you
win six awards in each six one's a
different agenda take a [ __ ] kill me but
exactly dude yeah I mean I worked in an
ABC there's a huge diversity initiatives
there and and my my sets very colorful
my set is incredibly diverse incredibly
and I have to say it used to not be so
so there's something there I think
there's always something there I'm not
saying you know yeah okay so Kansas City
Chiefs defensive tackle Derek
nattie yeah after winning the Super Bowl
he actually went and paid for all of the
adoption fees at a local shelter for all
91 dog song
okay cool cool
um and how much was that uh $50 that's
not true it's like four I think hundred
fifty is the most it's like 40 to 150
yeah and then how many was it so I'm
nine ninety when dogs nine thousand
bucks
you know what more than we what we did
sure it's nice yeah that's cool yeah
he's doing his own version of a foster
home for kids how much gonna cost me a
hundred and fifty dollars per kid so
then anyone could just come get their
pet right for free yeah
so anyone going to that shelter can go
and adopt the dog for free that's very
sweet
that's very nice like when the rock gave
his main stunt double a for Brooke yeah
mm-hmm what he what he was like did I
want to do something nice for Evan
thinking four years you've been i stunk
that for 15 years here's a four truck
that was now sites the least I could do
baby you know I got you you know I got
you hey that's nice Forge when your main
sponsors make a thought for it if they
did it what it what it run yeah 17 18
grand you're right he did that for his a
housekeeper to everybody game board era
buyer by getting for it so everybody can
afford he did let me say and it's a nice
thing man he's taking the dick I mean do
you watch the video I seen it oh it
seems a cousin Gestapo double is his
cousin Oh which I mean yeah I don't know
um I suppose like that's like me be like
right you've been my friend so many
years I get you some CBD oil like it's
the least I could do for you man get you
some baby I was on a plane with Frank's
Grillo's stunt double and with and he
also did stunt doubles for
Robert Downey jr. and for Ben Stiller
okay
he's top of the game and he looks so
much like Frank I was just laughing I
think Greg Fitz Fitzpatrick great guy
great guy and it was just like my age
though you know my age I'm like wow
that's not easy it's not easy oh you got
a stake constantly in shape but wow
that's cool various various oh you can
play a lot of different people yeah he
can yes he can
it's a tough gig Danny's Johnny Depp
yeah yeah look oh he does it all dude
he's as big as it gets
that's not him hell of a guy but you
know basically don't know Joe do
everything stuntman is no joke
no also though like you want to be
around them like they being top stuntmen
that there is stop some men are just you
just enjoy being around them and he was
so [ __ ] nice like he says the wait to
the flight attendant he goes thank you
thank you for being so pleasant you were
just you really made the flight great
like he's just one of those dudes I fell
in love with him okay we end up talking
in the in the front of the plane or I
don't know [ __ ] power kids in shape
he's built like a brick [ __ ] what
we we had we made out let me finish
you gotta optimize during the day you
gotta optimize at night a lot of
people's don't optimize at night yeah I
do honey for solid on supplements for
tonight you got digested with oh yes you
got that you got stuck for sweet yes for
night for the night on it's good for
vampires too if you if you are live at
night if you want to recover at night
even vampires could benefit from on it
you want to focus with your brain memory
and all that alpha brain you can do it
during the day too man yeah man do it
during the day get you some freakin
krill oil joint oil maybe you don't have
time to work out cool on it six
bodyweight workout from your phone do it
in your hotel room do it in your living
room doing your bathroom doing your
bedroom doing your closet man do your
closet it's amazing you do it
they got amazing you can create your own
gym too with the best quality everything
about them is the best qualities the
bestest eyes equipment supplements
everything on it calms last fight
attempts enough everything everything
earthing
what else you got cat okay so Jimmy
Martinez sent this in specifically for
you Brendan
because dung crews are coming back in
2024 good oh damn my son abhi Kron where
our dunkaroos I've never done gurus are
those old Mikey yeah it's like a cookie
that you dip into vanilla frosting
waiting oh yeah they were nice yeah yeah
a little cookie cook
I wonder who brought him back this this
is the there was like a fake thing that
went around a couple years back where
people said that dunkaroos were gonna
come back they the company had to come
out and say no we're not bringing this
back and there were so many people
throughout the years who continuously
brought up how good dung crews were that
they finally were like [ __ ] it I love
you back but here's the thing I love
them when I was a kid sometimes try [ __ ]
now Oh as long as I love this kid you
watch them they don't hold up hmm but
maybe they're not for us anymore I see
my son would dig him though cookies an
icing yeah okay commercials nothing yet
another one give us one more um all
right let me get a good one then this
one I've seen this firefighter that got
fired for her Instagram posts know she
had lifetime peace she's uh she's so
built like Oh in a good way I got a girl
does she have a huge [ __ ] hey bro cuz if
not count out what my say take a look at
some of these posts nothing bad right so
she's wearing her attractive the great
eyes she's pretty and then here's one
right that's either actual cheeked up
your actual regular some on fire
hey she's chic does she put out put out
a fire with them cheeks no regulation
fire my pant that's it that's it that's
my parent man take it easy dude I get
this hose in my bag she's a [ __ ] she
the oh wait what's the problem here she
got fired for some of those posts and I
post some of those posts what was wrong
with them she had like over 20-something
complaints by her higher house I don't
what a bunch of [ __ ] but then you know
there's no one
I don't she's a male counterparts but
post you know shirtless pics not enough
and they're fine
what she's suing is so she's doing that
man Montana Montana if I was in Montana
that's really guys she doesn't she won't
be great guys that's why if I was doing
a gig in Montana to set the club on fire
literally I'm fire so she would come
oh there's every girl super built I did
she's bad she's at that Bill chin she's
just hot as [ __ ] dude a customer agreed
no did she come on just a lien a
stallion for uten that's just [ __ ]
stock cheap yo [ __ ] up man you say hey
Montana calm the [ __ ] down
she's got a gun but I smack me around
change probably look that is built
yeah it's bail she's hot man man not
your type Champa she she's too much for
me that's too much step up and put in
the old [ __ ] 53 year old college try
me and her should have kids yeah you
guys should give world rhythm look at
this oh my god I mean I'll try but she's
out sedan would be longer her goddamn
job back she's suing now she should let
me know it yeah she need to help with
the lawyer whatever you need I'm moral
boost if you need some sort of you meet
an old guy ton you can toss around like
a baton like a circus baton but I'm
gonna set up a [ __ ] showman look at
that throw me around like a circus
boishakh chin you hold the camera god
yeah what it says Virginia though chin
well that's part we just took that's a
female friend a job right there like
that look at her with a mask on that's a
hot dogger right every sure she's in
Montana chin yeah the the fire
departments like evergreen fire recipe
she's like I know she's a just fat
chance
probably claw hand
Italian and Armenian somebody's so
surprised Dagestan II she's a
firefighter from heaven yes she is dude
yes she is so I mean the posts aren't
that crazy all right they're just crazy
saying say hot just save me
look at her shooting there she's got
arms on her she's got arms to that your
arms and I do
I got [ __ ] I'm just up I'm pissed off
you know what I always wanted to make me
fall just yep
Oh before she had like 80,000 now it's
like 160 so you know I always wanted to
be there's more than that I agree I
always wanted to be husky I always
wanted to have the kind of body but guys
go hey Bryce bright beefy husky I want
to be beefy and I never will be good
night wanna be beefy let's end on this
this is a positive note
yeah I get that though Jesus how do you
fire somebody for having that good a
squat with that depth and range that's
my dad's [ __ ] depth and range and
look at the intensity in her eyes it's
cute too lover love wifey wifey wifey
wifey wife always talking about the fire
department come on man she's a shame
I'll buy whatever stickers you have a
nice deal with all the fellas but
staying in shape look at the deep squat
right there you know I bet she's good
hey I bet she's a fella she's good I
hate [ __ ] having a beer what's the
privacy second place alone so what funny
she's funny
it's not a big deal I'm sure she's not
sexual at all don't go that probably not
good with big hoses at all oh she's give
her her job back look at that everywhere
look at this depth unbelievable if it
was a dumb Smith press yes I'm a
dachshund point you know though if it
was a dude he'd never get fired let's
say let's show some [ __ ] dudes go to
hot fire
I want to make a feminist point let's
leave but leave leave the time with this
person I want to make a point on the
road this one book be no I'm on I'm on
the road in February 14 15 16 I'm gonna
be at the West Palm and Bailey Beach
improv buy your tickets West Palm Beach
improv February 14 15 16
I'm here wait yep I'm in Toronto neo
Thursday Friday Saturday shows almost
sold out Thursday Friday Saturday San
Antonio next week I'm on in Ontario for
the Valentine's Day weekend Thursday
Friday Saturday Ontario bring your
little lover birds on out Brendon I'll
be dressed like a fireman you can touch
him he'll be in a deep squat that
firefighter will be there she's opening
up for me that's my new opener oh yeah
and she sprays the crowd with water
Vancouver just for last Comedy Festival
vogue theater that was almost sold out
as well February 21st and I end the
month in Tacoma Washington then March
gets pretty frosty theater tour Chicago
Atlanta New Orleans Toronto Detroit
Minneapolis get your tickets tief at
kake.com this this is the five kid route